in this video I'm going to be spending
an entire day living like a clicker from
HBO's The Last of Us
to do this I made a costume and tried my
best to immerse myself in the life of a
clicker
and while this was all pretty fun it
also had some unexpected consequences my
wife left before we get there though
let's take a look at how I made the
costume and find out just what happened
that caused my wife to leave
it was actually pretty easy to make and
it only cost about 20 bucks I started
out with a plastic Halloween mask that
already looks terrifying and I duct
taped some cardboard to the top to act
as a base for the mask then I went
outside to spray some foam under the
mask because apparently the foam is
toxic and it might cause lung damage or
even kill me but anyways it looked
pretty good so then I went back inside
to get to carving this part actually
took quite a bit of time because I
really wanted it to look as much like a
clicker as possible but once I finished
that I got to painting and after about
four coats of paint it was time for the
finishing touches last but not least I
cut a set of zombie teeth in half and
glued them to the bottom of the Mask so
it would look just like a clicker that's
had its entire skull split into and now
for the finished product
oh I definitely can't see
oh my God he seemed to like it let's see
what my son thinks come here Bubba
this is my son Auggie and apparently he
loves the costume
go get him come here I can't see you are
you coming
so since everyone seemed to like the
costume I needed to test whether I could
actually live like a clicker that's
right it's echolocation time in case you
were wondering I can see absolutely
nothing in this mask so I'll have to
rely on echolocation like the clickers
to navigate my way around hey what's
echolocation well echolocation is the
act of using reflected sounds to locate
objects and in a sense see what's around
you now let's see if I can navigate in
public without being able to see
remember I couldn't see a thing so I
almost ran directly into this guy
he had like zero reaction but now for
the real question can I drive a car
foreign
I can't see let's go get some food
hi uh could I get a McChicken I really
can't see anything
is that like a mask or something
more uh The Last of Us
sure
what's up you're like pretty oh thank
you I love it so wait you guys need a
quarter inch drill bit do you have one
uh no
let's go get one
let's go get one so wait did you want to
go to Home Depot or Lowe's
um
[Music]
I wanted to live a day in the life of
this type of the infected because I feel
like they just lead really hard lives
they can't see they have to use
echolocations and all they want is to
spread their love in the form of fungus
they ran in before us because they were
they didn't want to be in public with us
[Applause]
thank you yeah
not out of her
[Music]
you're distracting you that's what we
need that made her day this is my new
best friend Vicky she's the sweetest
worker at Lowe's I've ever met so what
do you think of the Mask do you like it
[Music]
no helping us find what we need but
thank you
gotta use echolocation
did you get everything you needed yes I
think we did
you guys didn't die or anything brick
facade we got it then we decided to get
some drinks at Taco Bell can I just get
a large Baja Blast
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God where'd you get that from
please take this
thank you
now you're probably still wondering why
my wife left and it's because I did this
guy
don't worry she said she still loves me
but we'll have to wait and see what she
thinks of the stormtrooper armor I'm
building next
[Music]